now i've been super candid i've always
spoken up uh about how for the first
season of jackass i made less than 1500
bucks oh yeah same oh yeah like
i think that bam did like really well
because he kind of came in as a producer
like he had the whole cky thing going i
was uh it was like a 250 or 300 purse
done and we went to florida when i met
you and i came back and i had like 15
stunts and trip taylor called me and
said we have made a change it's now
three stunts for 300 bucks oh yeah yeah
and and
by then it was the second season yeah
paid per stunt on the second oh yeah
absolutely absolutely then you got
screwed because they uh we all got
screwed
after the second season or sorry i have
the first season there and i'd made the
purse stunt bit but then they paid me 2
000 per episode on the second season and
the third season did they pay up front
or just like a week like half up front
wow and and so after taxes uh i half up
front was uh ten thousand bucks now if i
didn't go on the road with you i would i
would have been a bill to make it you
know that's the don't try this at home
tour
yeah yeah no i had a job driving a
limousine at that time and i had a hug
took some people out on the town had a
great time went great and then all of a
sudden they called and said hey
um we've noticed that that was where the
guys from jackass on there we thought we
were going to be pranked we'd like our
money back and my boss is like you are
fired you can't do this no way and i was
like that grave and great service had a
good time but they just started thinking
about it and we're like wait a minute we
could get this whole thing for free you
know oh damn so i was fired from the
limousine business hold some porn people
around though that was pretty
interesting oh yeah because you go out
to the airport and pick them up and
they're just bright-eyed and
bushy-tailed and you go and they spend a
week in hollywood usually like five days
then that limousine right back to go to
ohio or michigan was a sad deal they had
the little shame yeah it's the look of
shame and they also do 250 300 per stunt
kind of in the same same pay league
there
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and sky
jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]
me